[Music]
hey you guys
doing another book review today this was
another recommendation
from uh one of the booktube channels
that i watch
uh who's as jordaline reads and i take
like a lot of her recommendations
because
you know hers her taste and my taste
seem to be very very similar
and she really talked a lot about this
book and i was like okay i gotta get
this and read it because it sounded like
really awesome
so this is uh the good house by
tanana reeve do now it's really weird
because
when i first ordered this book and
started reading it i didn't realize even
though the bulk of it is set in
2001 and a couple years after that i
didn't realize until i looked it up
later on
that the book actually came out way the
hell back in 2004
so you know i i was thinking it was kind
of like just a couple years old but it's
actually quite old and it is actually
said at the time
that it was written i thought it was you
know just set like a few
like still like it had been written to
be back then but it was like modern but
it's not it was actually came out in
2004.
now uh tinana reeve do has done a lot of
a lot of books and this is the first
novel of hers that i've read i actually
saw her
she was on the um the shutter
documentary horror noir
uh you know history of black horror so
she's in that she's i believe she's a
professor
and uh teaches about uh horror films
particularly those of jordan peele
and stuff like that so i'm really glad
that i finally got around to reading one
of her books because
this just it sounded really cool and it
sounded like right up my alley
so even though the book is called the
good house you might
think it kind of sounds like it would be
a haunted house novel
but it's not exactly um it does have to
do with the house and there is like
creepy [ __ ] going on in the house
but it's not exactly it's not exactly
ghosts it's kind of like a different
thing so like i said
if you just like i say on these you know
reviews usually
if you don't want to know anything if
you want to know jack [ __ ] about this
book before going into it
then probably don't watch this review
i'm not going to spoil anything i'm not
going to spoil the end
however you know to discuss it i am
going to have to
basically say what happens in it at some
points and if you don't want to know
anything
then you know go read the book and then
come back now i will say
this book is a big chunky boy uh it's
about 500 pages
and uh the and the text inside at least
in the paperback is a very very dense so
this actually took me probably
four or five days to read which is very
long time for me uh and in
matter of fact i was supposed to review
it last week but
i didn't have enough time to finish it
in time so i had to do stir of echoes
instead because that was so much shorter
and i already had already read it and i
wanted to be able to like devote some
time to this one because this story
it's kind of like it's i don't know if
sprawling is the right word and i don't
even want to say multi-generational
because
it's mostly set in the present day or at
least the present when this was written
it's set like i said in 2001 and in 2004
but it does kind of go back and forth in
time a little bit and there are a lot of
different characters
and it has to do with a large extended
family and also
a small town and kind of like the
interconnections between all of those
people
so at the heart of the story is a woman
named angela
and she is um she was a lawyer and then
she went to be like a um
like a hollywood agent type of thing so
she's kind of like an up-and-coming
agent she's got like a couple of clients
that are you know just
about ready to break out and be really
famous so she's kind of well known she's
got money and everything
and um so she's been living in l.a
uh and her ex-husband tariq and her son
corey who's a teenager
have actually been living in oakland
since her and tariq have been
separated for four years now what ends
up happening
is that at some point one summer she's
been coming back to this little bitty
town it's a fictional town
uh it's actually it's a real town but
you
but tenana reef do change the name of it
because she says in the in the back
acknowledgements she's like
hey sorry this town in washington that i
you know changed the name of your town
but that's the town that she used for
reference
so this town is called sacagawea and
it's in washington state
and angela grew up there and so
every summer she still owns the property
that's there which is called the good
house
it's called the good house because the
dude that built it
uh his last name was josiah good i think
was his last name like with an e at the
end
and also because um for a long time
angela's grandmother grandma marie
she lived there and she's kind of like i
don't want to say it's exactly like
voodoo but it's like voodoo adjacent you
know what i mean so she was kind of like
you know i guess what most americans
would call a voodoo priestess
um she made like these herbal teas that
would cure people and things like that
so she was kind of like
it's really interesting they don't go a
lot into
i mean pretty much like the opening
prologue
is set back in 1929 when grandma marie
was still
alive and what ended up happening
she had a husband a common-law husband
who was native american
and the other people in the town didn't
really like
them but they kind of she kind of had
this
situation where she had started out
grandma marie had started out as the
housekeeper for josiah good and after he
died
he left her the house in his will and it
was this really really nice
mansion essentially and so a lot of the
townspeople didn't like that because she
was black
and then also you know it was the 20s
and uh
you know and so then she kind of takes
up with a native american man who the
townspeople kind of who they called red
john
uh you know just kind of to be [ __ ] and
the people were kind of shitty to them
even though like on the down low they
would come and get teas and stuff from
her because she had
you know there was rumors that she was
you know had knew how to do magic and
stuff
so in 1929 there's a mudslide
in sacagawea and it basically wipes out
the entire town
except for the good house and after that
people had
a better opinion of grandma marie
because she helped everybody
and also it seems at the very beginning
that
the townspeople bring this girl to her
that's acting very very strangely
and as the story goes on you realize
that this was kind of like an
instigating event this
girl or this child was um
basically ridden by a baka you know like
it's essentially like a demon but more
like a voodoo adjacent kind of
demon and grandma marie tried to get it
out of there and all this other stuff so
apparently
so that's that's kind of like the
prologue part and then it kind of comes
up to the present day now in the present
day
uh angela is trying to get back together
with tariq
they're staying at the good house over
the summer they're having a fourth of
july party
uh corey the teenage son has been acting
very very strangely
and it so happens at this party and as i
said if you don't want to know any
you know plot threads or anything like
that um this one i think is given away
like it's pretty early in the story so i
don't feel too bad about it
but corey ends up either accidentally or
on purpose
shooting himself in the head and killing
himself in the cellar of the house
and after this particular event
things really start spiraling downwards
and it's kind of like
as i said this is a very very long
intricate
almost kind of like a multi-general
generational type of story because
as it goes on it turns out that grandma
marie
back in you know the early 20th century
she was even though she was a very
powerful
um like i said as you would call a
voodoo priestess a mambo i guess is what
they call it in the book so she
was that but apparently she had done
something to piss off
the spirits and she was trying to fix it
and she couldn't really fix it so
after she died she had apparently been
trying to
contact angela to get her to fix her
mistake
so that ever so that you know the um you
know the waves from this
demonic possession essentially wouldn't
stretch out over the entire
town however angela seems like she's
been kind of
she doesn't really believe in that kind
of thing she's a very modern woman
you know she loved her grandma but she
just couldn't get into all that like
quote unquote superstition and all this
other kind of [ __ ]
so it's almost kind of like she closed
her mind
to the past and to all of these
possibilities
so apparently what had happened was that
grandma marie had tried to contact her
son corey
instead corey got a little um
over excited and was like oh my god i
found all grandma marie's stuff and it's
like now i can do magic and he kind of
[ __ ] it up too
while he's trying to fix it and that was
again like the instigating incident that
made
the spirit or the baca like much much
stronger
now what this demon can do is
basically can possess people and it
seemed like he could possess
or it could possess more than one person
at once because it could basically
take over your whole personality and
make you do horrible things you would
kill your own children you could just do
all kind of [ __ ]
and it could do stuff like because at
one point
angela and her uh client slash friend
naomi are at the the good house and
naomi's little dog her she has a little
poodle named onyx
and he disappears and for a long time
you think he's dead but then like he
turns up later on and so
so the demon can actually make things
can actually pretty like transport
objects
like to wherever they need to be um you
know guns
cars anything so it can so it's very
very powerful it does it's actually more
powerful at the good house and this
and the woods behind it because it's
like a really big property there's a
whole thing too like not only had
grandma marie live there and there was
all those
spirits in the woods but there was also
like a
you know native american there was a
burial ground and all this other stuff
so all this magic was kind of coming
together it was kind of like this
the woods were kind of like this uh
crossroads i guess like where the
the veil between the living and the dead
was was very very thin
and so that's why a lot of people who
were
magically inclined let's call it that
way um
were kind of drawn to this place because
it was a very it was a place of power
uh for both good or ill now so as i said
this
the way the story goes is kind of like
angela
having to come back to the town and
you know after her son dying and seeing
the destruction that this spirit is
wreaking on not only her family but on
the entire town
and her having to come to terms with the
fact that
magic is real and that it actually works
and
you know her being able to have you know
to come back and like fix it
so as i said this is um i really really
loved the hell out of this book i just
i thought it was just so so good it's
not it has
a lot of really like creepy like
unsettling
types of images uh there's a lot of
i mean it's quite violent um there's you
know there's a lot of kind of ex
not really explicit sex in it but um
just the writing is just really
evocative and beautiful um i could just
see this whole entire town i could see
the house
and there's just this the way that the
demon
manifests itself sometimes is
really creepy like it can look like a
person or
it can you know ride a person and make
them
do its bidding um and that person kind
of looks the same except like with a
weird grin or they smell really bad
like they have like a really pungent
smell to them that if you're
s that not everybody can smell it but if
you're sensitive to it you know you can
smell it and that kind of thing and also
it can appear
as uh like once it appears as kind of
this little
blonde girl in the woods and uh you know
sometimes it appeals as like appears
like piles of leaves because it's kind
of like
i guess it's kind of like a spirit that
sort of comes out of the ground so it's
like
like nature spirits you know what i mean
so it's that kind of thing
but yeah so i will say it took me a
little bit of time
to get into it like i said it's a very
it's quite long
it's very involved you re there's a lot
of characters
you really have to pay attention i don't
think it's that hard to pay attention to
it's not like it's
densely written or anything it's very
very clearly written that's you know she
has a really lovely
writing style but you really do have to
pay attention to
you know the relationships between all
the family members the relationships
between all the townsfolk
like you know who is this and what
happened in the past because some of the
people
that live in the town had some [ __ ] that
happened you know
back when grandma marie was alive and
you know knows things about her and
stuff
so you really have to like keep track of
all this this large web
of uh you know of relationships to
really get the full
effect out of it but that said
um as i said i didn't really have any
trouble doing that uh but i did want to
take a little bit more time with it just
because
it was so long and involved and i really
wanted to give it my full attention
and i'm glad that i did because it's a
really it's just like a really
immersive experience i guess like you
just when you're reading it you just
kind of get lost
in it and like i said i think that a lot
of that has to do with the writing and
the imagery
the characters are really really
involving all of the characters are
really
complicated they're not all like oh this
is a good guy this is a bad guy
it's like some of the people like
particularly tariq uh you know her
uh angela's ex-husband who is
kind of a [ __ ] but also he's got
like really good qualities too
um you know so he's not a terrible
terrible person but you can understand
like why she couldn't put up with him
you know what i mean
she is also not a perfect character
either i mean obviously she's
the protagonist she's the hero but she's
also got a lot of
her own problems she's very bossy she's
very overly rational she'll
listen to any of this superstition crap
she's so you can see
like all of the relationships which
particularly between her
and tariq and corey you know the teenage
son you know
he's having a hard time with her too
before he um before he
dies he's having a hard time with her
too because he just finds her very
like oh she's all she does is talk she
doesn't listen to me
um you know so so there's like all these
complex relationships that i think are
really really well
uh played out and there's also a
relationship too between angela
and when she goes back to the town of
sacajawea she goes back and she meets
her essentially her high school
boyfriend
miles and uh so there's kind of some
stuff going on there so there's all this
complicated stuff going on with
you know her still still having feelings
for him and like you know tariq wanting
to come back and
you know get back together for the sake
of their son and they're trying to work
things out
so there's all this other kind of stuff
going on too like all this kind of
family drama
now i did watch i read some reviews of
it on
goodreads and like i said most of the
reviews seemed really really good but
some people said well it's not really
a horror novel i didn't see i disagree
with that i think this is very much a
horror novel
um it did remind me some people said it
reminded them of stephen king i'd
the writing style is not stephen
king-ish i think the reason people are
saying that is because
maybe it's kind of this complicated
interweb of
characters like in a small town you know
and there's this past
evil that you know people have to get
together and fight
in that sense yeah it's stephen king but
a lot of other horror novels are like
that as well
but yeah i definitely definitely think
this is a horror it's essentially a
demon possession novel
but it's not not with a quote-unquote
christian
overlay it's it's more like like i said
more voodoo adjacent
uh type of stuff which is cool because
you don't really see a lot of that like
in horror novels or at least not most of
the ones that i've read
it seems like it's an underexplored area
so i think it's a really cool
uh so i think it was a really cool like
framework to kind of explore
the idea of messing with magic or
messing with powers that probably you
shouldn't be messing with
you know people's arrogance or greed or
whatever
you know making you want to use these
powers that are seemingly at your
fingertips but how
something like that can go horribly
horribly wrong and how
the repercussions of that thing that you
did
can resonate just throughout generations
and generations because essentially
grandma marie back in the 1920s or
whenever her mistake
resonated for three or four generations
down there just because the spirits were
so angry at her at what she'd done
and you know the fact of her trying to
reach corey to get him to fix it him not
him being a teenager and not really
knowing what he was doing
not really taking the time to learn how
to do things correctly he wanted
everything right now
and that ended up going tragically wrong
as well so i think that's kind of like
the main theme of the book is just
not to mess with stuff you don't
understand because it might have
uh terrible terrible results that you
don't envision and then they might
resonate as i said
you know way down your family line way
you know to people who
aren't even related to you but are just
like you know friends family and all
this other kind of stuff so i think that
was kind of the main theme of the novel
i really really dug that
another criticism that people had and i
don't agree with this one either was
that they didn't like
the end and i'm not really sure what
they're getting at i'm not sure if they
don't they didn't like the resolution of
you know how
the battle turned out or if they didn't
like
the sort of coda at the end now
i really dug the ending i mean honestly
um i i thought it
kind of resolved itself perfectly and
then the coda at the end
i'm not going to lie it actually kind of
made me tear up a little bit it was just
kind of like
i don't it was like a really touching
ending
and i was actually really happy that it
ended that way because it seemed like
i don't know like i said i don't want to
spoil the ending so what i was going to
say was probably like spoil the editing
a little bit so i'm not going to say it
but i really really like the way the
story resolved
um i was very happy with it as i said i
think the
strength of this is just i loved
you know the the framework the whole you
know magic thing like i said which
you know voodoo type of stuff you don't
really see a lot of that in horror which
i thought was really cool
uh the character work amazing i really
really liked all the um
you know the descriptions it's just you
know the the description of the town the
description of the house
all the familiar relationships it was
just really really well done
and it's like it was weird it took me a
little bit to get into i think because
at first it kind of jumps around in time
a lot you know let's say first we're at
1929 we're talking about the mudslide
and we're talking about the kid with the
demon and like grandma murray trying to
help the kid with the demon and then
we're jumping ahead to 2001 to the
fourth of july party
where uh corey kills himself and there
were so we're kind of jumping around
from character to character
so it took me a little while to figure
out well how do all these threads tie
together
but then as the story goes it just
really kind of like sucks you in and you
just kind of get
all into and you're just all interested
in all these characters and what's
happening in their lives
and as the story goes on it's almost
kind of like it's weaving
uh the story together like as it's going
and it was just really
i don't know it was just like a very
satisfying feeling for me like
seeing where all of the things were
weaving together like as i was reading
it
so yeah it's just funny that i that i
had just it sounded good like from the
descriptions of you know that i had seen
and
i was just kind of like oh that sounds
good i'm gonna buy that i don't even
remember if this was on my tbr
because i think i might have ordered it
more recently than uh you know that i
ordered it after i did that video so i'm
not really sure
but i don't know i just i heard a couple
people like like i said you know other
book reviewers that i like to watch on
youtube
and a couple of them had talked about
how awesome it was and i was like man
that sounds really good
and um so i bought it and i like i said
when i bought it i didn't realize that
it had come out that long ago but
it doesn't matter um i didn't actually
realize what i was reading it
that it wasn't like a modern social oh
it's set in 2001 or it's set in 2004 or
whatever it's like
it wasn't really a deal breaker for me
it was just funny that it took me this
long to get around to reading it but you
know but at least i finally did right
but yeah so
definitely gonna be seeking out more of
her stuff uh because this book was
really really enjoyable
uh so yeah if that sounds like something
you'd like just a big sprawling family
epic you know with some sort of
voodoo-ish
magic uh to it uh you know i i think
you'd really dig it so
uh definitely check it out as i said
it's called the good house
by tanana reeve dew and i will see you
guys
on the next one bye